You could almost imagine that there's a conversation
going on between a psychic and a detective to solve a murder mystery.
The detective is at a dead end and can't figure out how to solve the murder mystery
and the psychic has this sort of amazing leap--oh, you need to check the finger prints on the body.
This maybe not that amazing of a leap and you'll find that the murderer is Smith.
Now, we wouldn't arrest someone based on just the word of the psychic.
This detective now actually needs to go and check it out and see that it is actually is true,
and assuming that the psychic is giving checkable information and it's correct,
then the two of them together should be able to solve the problem.
Now the role of the psychic here is actually to pick the accepting certificate,
I don't know out of thin air or somehow, just guess it
and then the verification algorithm actually can check it.
This actually explains this notion guessing a certificate pulling out of thin air.
It's not a deterministic process.
It's not something that we could just program an algorithm to do
to just jump right to the right answer and that makes it a non-deterministic step.
It's not the kind of thing that you can actually write into a program that proceeds step by step by step.
It sorts of make this crazy leap, non-deterministic leap
and as long as we can check that leap is correct with the verification algorithm,
we can at least conceptualize that this is a way of solving problems.
We can actually implement a computer like this, but we can imagine a computer
that we call a non-deterministic computer, non-deterministic turing machine
that could this sort of magical step
and that's where NP gets its name, non-deterministic polynomial time.
And just a quick aside, there are actually some researchers working on something like this.
There's reasons to believe that a quantum computer can do certain kinds of guessing,
essentially by in parallel kind of imagining all the different situations that all these different certificates
that might exists, and then designing the algorithm in such a way that the correct certificate
will actually bubble up to the top efficiently.
This doesn't exist yet so don't get worry
that what your learning in computer science is all completely irrelevant.
It's still relevant for as far as we can tell into the future
but the idea of a quantum computer is actually very interesting.
We have reason to believe that the design and analysis of algorithms for quantum computer
are going to lean pretty heavily on the stuff that we do for classical computers as well.